bonjour tout le monde au grand mot les
grands moyens la crise provoquée par la
covid 19 a forcé le gouvernement de
Justin Trudeau a réagir rapidement on
reconnaît la pression de devoir aider
les gens le plus rapidement possible
mais pour ce faire du renfort a été
nécessaire la taille de la fonction
publique fédérale a considérablement
augmenté CBC Radio-Canada a pris qu'on
compte environ 35000 employés de plus
qu'avant la pandémie une augmentation de
12%. ces nouvelles embauches ont un coût
la facture du gouvernement s'est
alourdie d'environ 4 milliards et demi
de dollars en 2021
on demande au gouvernement d'en faire
davantage et ses chiffres le démontre
ceci dit il est d'avis qu'il faudra un
plan détaillé pour les années à venir
quatre départements se taillent la part
du lion l'agence de revenus du Canada
responsable des programmes d'aide comme
la BCE que 10 000 employés de plus si
emploi et développement social Canada
responsable des passeports notamment
8500 emplois se sont ajoutés il y a près
de 2000 postes de plus qu'avant à
l'Agence de santé publique du Canada et
finalement 1750 personnes ont intégré
les bureaux d'immigration réfugiés et
citoyenneté Canada afin de gérer les
crises en Afghanistan et en Ukraine
entre autres est-ce une bonne chose pour
les Canadiens ça dépend si vous vous
pensez que c'était important d'avoir des
soutiens comme PCI ou bien des services
que
l'agence peut revenir au Canada a nous a
donné mais d'autres s'interrogent le
gouvernement pourra-t-il tenir le rythme
la taille de la fonction publique
fédérale augmente constamment depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir des libéraux en
2015 le gouvernement insiste soutenir
les Canadiens demeure sa priorité ici
qui me permettra au Canada Montréal